マックナゲットって
何キロカロリーでしょうか。
元店員マックナゲット何キロカロリー(・・?
一箱280キロカロリーなので、
280×20わ五千六百キロカロリー
今こちらに5600キロカロリーのマックナゲットwwwが
あるんですけどもぉ！俺は東京で何を身に着けたか
so！大群の群れに流されない力！
・・・。
（　＾ω＾）・・・
。。。
それだけだっっっっっっっ！！！！
といわけで早速今日は
バックナゲットwwwを100一人で食っていこう
と思います。
頂きます！！！！！！！
最近マジで
あのフードファイター才能あるんじゃねえべか
感じがするんで
速攻で見せつけていければいいなとおもっております
いただきます
ﾊﾞｸﾊﾞｸﾑｼｬﾑｼｬﾓｯﾁｬﾓｯﾁｬ
％◎○○％×
ｳﾏ！ｳｳﾏ！！！
美味しくいただいてる間に
一つナゲッツの豆知識いっていいすか
ｱ､ｵﾈｼｬｽ
なんか、
私
元マッｋ
ﾁｬﾁｬﾁｬﾁｬ
ﾏｽﾞﾜ10個ﾀﾍﾞﾏｼﾀ
％×◎○○ｺﾚｶﾗﾃﾞｽﾖ
や、100個はもー、
20超えた男だったらよゆーでっせ
ここからが大人
ﾅﾙﾎﾄﾞﾈ！
％×○◎○×％×ﾈ！
いくつですか今
20個食べました！
ｳﾝ
ﾅﾙﾎﾄﾞﾈ(本日2回目
こゆーかんじか
(*￣-￣)ふ～ん
そうくるのねー
なーるほどっっっっ！
おもむきぶけぇわ。
ﾔﾊﾞｲﾅｺﾚ
突然の死
どっかいった？(魂)
体ン中でやめてくれって叫んでる(？)
体がやめてくれって叫びたがってるんだ｡(絶賛上映中)
このままだと本当に
ま、バックナゲットwww上から出るか×２(こちらも絶賛上映中)
ま、食べれる―たべていくんですけどー
100までたべるのはむりなんで
おなかすいてるんでしょ？
これだって何個今？(超激怒)
二十、、、６とかですよね
赤ちゃん(おこ)
2人で協力してとりま100こたべよ
そんでよゆーがあったら２００いこ
あぁ～絶対行きますよ(怒)
こんだけ言ってて食えないわけない　お・れ・が！！(おこ
本気頼む！
ﾊﾞｸﾊﾞｸﾑｼｬﾑｼｬﾓｯﾁｬﾓｯﾁｬﾊﾞｸﾊﾞｸﾑｼｬﾑｼｬﾓｯﾁｬﾓｯﾁｬ
(」・ω・)」うー！(／・ω・)／まー！
噓でしょ(激おこプーチン丸)
今30？
30...
ねえほんとやばいからね！？！？！？(おこ)
このままだとなゲッツ親子になっちゃう
(爆笑)
突然の涙
ｳｳｳ...
ねーえー垂れてる垂れてる！
ｱｯｱｯすーごーい！
ガチなきしてるじゃん
...ﾊｧー
ずる！
(´Д｀)ﾊｧ…
(爆笑 )
ﾊﾞｸﾊﾞｸﾑｼｬﾑｼｬﾓｯﾁｬﾓｯﾁｬﾊﾞｸﾊﾞｸﾑｼｬﾑｼｬﾓｯﾁｬﾓｯﾁｬ
ﾊｲ！
おーお疲れ様でーす
とわけでいま３１個30個
になっております。
あれだけ自信満々だったようですが...
30個食べて。。。どうですか！
まいっちゃう
えでもー俺見たんだよいろんな
ユーチューバーの方がー１００ことかたべてるんですけどー
みんなね！3人とか４人とか
こうなんかこぞってやってるんすよ
あめえよ！！！！(おこなう)
俺は2人でやるよ(キリッ)
皆さんなんか3－4人ぐらいでナゲット食べてるんで
2人で頑張ろう！
お互いっここだｋ...
食べればいいから。
頑張っていこう！！！！！！！
よし！
野郎！！！
ん.なにぃ？
ﾊﾞｸﾊﾞｸﾑｼｬﾑｼｬﾓｯﾁｬﾓｯﾁｬﾊﾞｸﾊﾞｸﾑｼｬﾑｼｬﾓｯﾁｬﾓｯﾁｬﾊﾞｸﾊﾞｸﾑｼｬﾑｼｬﾓｯﾁｬﾓｯﾁｬﾊﾞｸﾊﾞｸﾑｼｬﾑｼｬﾓｯﾁｬﾓｯﾁｬ
(´Д｀)ﾊｧ…も普通に限界
((笑))
たぶん３０がげんかいですね
待って...
マックの人...渡しすぎじゃね？
なんかソース...なに100個ついてんの！？
一人に一個ずつお風呂あるみたいな感じ
そういう...
それがいちばん大変なことになってる
ほらみて
二つの世界を行き来する時を越えるナゲッツ　　　　(絶賛上映中)
あ、あかちゃんかもー
(大爆笑)
うまくゆってる？
ん？
あの
ナゲットゴー
(大大大爆笑)
ﾊﾞｸﾊﾞｸﾑｼｬﾑｼｬﾓｯﾁｬﾓｯﾁｬﾊﾞｸﾊﾞｸﾑｼｬﾑｼｬﾓｯﾁｬﾓｯﾁｬ
ｳｯﾌﾟ
最初はグージャンケンポン
待ってよー
元店員(バイト)｢(笑)｣
待って待っても―無理無理
最初はグージャンケンポン
あいこでしょ！
バイト爆笑
バイツ大爆笑
バイツァ・ダスト「(笑)」
バイトジャングル「(笑)」
ここはフェアにねやっぱじゃんけん
いやフェアじゃないよ！！！！！(激おこプーチン丸)
最初はグージャンケンポン
いやチョキだそうとおもったんだよ…
ｳｳｳ
さあラスト2個となりました。
ジャンケンポン
ちょっとまってくれよ～
最初はグージャンケンぽぉぉん
ﾝﾝ
冗談抜きで
ﾊﾝﾊﾟﾅｶｯﾀﾃﾞｽ
多分普通の人は
1人で50個たべることは相当困難だと思うので
是非自信のない方は絶対にしないでください
バイバイ！！
この字幕みたよってひとは高評価押してね！！
よろしく！！！